good morning hank it's tuesday so i have
approximately one idea every five years
like in 2006 i had an idea called
vlogbrothers and then five years later i
had an idea called crash course and then
five years after that i had an idea
called the anthropocene reviewed and now
i am patiently awaiting my fourth idea
hank you meanwhile have one idea every
20 seconds like i would say that on 7
000 separate occasions you've called me
and said i have a million dollar idea if
i had an actual million dollars for
every million dollar idea hank has
pitched me i would have like seven
billion dollars or nearly three percent
of jeff bezos's wealth when it comes to
ideas in general hank's job is to be
extremely enthusiastic and my job is to
be extremely dubious and to be fair to
hank he has had many wonderful ideas
from vidcon to scishow to subable hank
has helped make amazing things but to be
fair to me hank has also had lots of
terrible ideas i'm talking about
surprisingly edible a store that only
sells things that don't appear to be
edible and also pellet fans hank's only
fans for pelicans this is where my
anxious dread filled deeply dubious
filter comes in and if a hank idea
survives that filter it's a great idea
and almost without exception i have
wholeheartedly approved of all of hank's
best ideas
almost without exception my first
failure was in 2009 hank called me and
said i have a million dollar idea and i
sighed and then he said i want to make
special glasses that render 3d movies in
a crisp two dimensions and i was like
that's the worst idea i've ever heard
and hank was like no a lot of people
want to go see 3d movies with their
friends or family or whatever but they
get headaches and so 2d glasses would be
a great service to them and i was like
okay i mean that's an idea it's not a
million dollar idea but
it's an idea now i was right 2d glasses
did not make a million dollars but i was
also wrong because they were very
successful but more to the point i was
wrong on a deeper level because 2d
glasses changed both of our lives
because with 2d glasses hank realized
that his ideas could become things if
the idea of 2d glasses could become 2d
glasses then the idea of a conference
could become vidcon the idea of an
educational video company could become
complexly the idea of me with a mustache
could become a t-shirt and so on so i
was wrong but not as wrong as i was a
couple years ago when hank called me and
told me that he and some folks at
dftba.com had worked up a million dollar
idea a sock subscription i don't know
why in thinking about how to raise more
money for charity hank arrived at socks
but i'm very glad he did here is the
idea as hank pitched it to me what if
every month a pair of wonderful socks
arrived at your house and your ankles
were happy and all of the profit not
some or most but all went to support
stronger health care systems in
impoverished communities and i was like
that is not a million dollar idea
and i was wrong or at least hopefully i
soon will be wrong because the awesome
socks club has raised over seven hundred
thousand dollars for charity in its
first year i was wrong i was wrong i was
wrong i wish being wrong were always
this lovely i was wrong on every level
because in addition to supporting an
important cause in such a big way
awesome socks club socks are my favorite
socks like for reasons we don't have to
get into i am currently booted but
thanks to the awesome socks club i am
able to maintain my high level of
fashion even with my boot so yeah i hope
this is the year that hank proves me
fully wrong and the awesome socks club
becomes a literal million dollar idea
because it is doing a lot of good
awesomesocks.club you can only sign up
for the next few days this is the part
where i disclose it's a sponsored video
but no it's not a sponsored video nobody
paid for this awesome socks.club you
gotta go now i think i'll see you on
friday p.s i just want to be very clear
about something hank just because i was
wrong about this one thing does not mean
that i am wrong about surprisingly
edible which continues to not be a good
idea okay that's all don't
don't you dare